well the lawyer for the family of a
University of Maryland football player
who died after an intense workout is
calling for the head football coach to
be fired
Jordan McNair died 15 days after showing
signs of heat stroke and collapsing on
the field an ESPN report alleges a toxic
coaching culture may have played a role
Tony - copal is at UMD Tony good morning
a good morning to members of the
University of Maryland football coaching
staff are on what they're calling
administrative leave this morning that
includes the head coach and it all comes
as the university investigates claims
that those coaches created a toxic
culture include including abuse
intimidation the threat of humiliation
as well and all of it allegedly
contributing to the death of Jordan
McNear we have individual head hyperbole
according to ESPN it was about 80
degrees on May 29th when Jordan McNair
showed signs of extreme heat exhaustion
about 45 minutes into a preseason
workout witnesses told ESPN the
offensive lineman had difficulty
standing while running a hundred and ten
yard Sprint's a tough but common workout
for many football teams he then had
convulsions and suffered a seizure
before collapsing on the field McNair
was taken to a hospital where he died 15
days later the conduct of the coaches
was reprehensible in causing this death
bill Murphy is the McNair family
attorney he says coaches should have
seen the warning signs is this man
suffering from the symptoms of
heatstroke an answer that would have
been yes yes yes and he would have been
taken into the training room and iced
down in June coach Durkin responded to
news of McNair's death my heart is
broken it's not reasonable that
the 19 year old she passed away but
several current and former UMD football
players and staffers including the
Canaris family believe a coaching style
defined by intimidation is partly to
blame according to ESPN
there was often extreme verbal abuse
coaches would throw weights toward
players and some players claimed if a
teammate was on the ground from
exhaustion staff would drag them off the
ground and make them run a player was
once allegedly belittled for passing out
during a drill the McNair family is now
considering legal action a suit is
absolutely probable the question is one
of them going to do it now the
University of Maryland wrote to us in a
statement promising a full investigation
and saying humiliating and the meeting a
student is not only bad teaching and
coaching it is an abuse of the authority
of a teacher and coach we should also
add that this is all still under
investigation and some players and
coaches have come forward to speak in
praise of head coach Durkin Alex Tony
thank you